he shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood and
i put it all over me
why only in america why is this american
exceptionalism
so awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it
you get your political agenda no it's us
god love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why you do not think
that guns are the problem
[Music]
whatever the politicians say there are
indisputable facts about america's
relationship with guns first more
american children die from gun violence
than anything else
second the gun death rate in america is
much higher than most other countries
globally and it is the highest of all
developed nations and the third most
depressing fact every time there is a
mass shooting especially in a school the
calls come for change for reform for new
laws but it never happens how many more
innocent american lives
must be taken before we say enough
so what about this time after you valdi
a massacre of such ferocity that most of
the 19 little children who died had to
be identified by dna could their deaths
this time provide the jolt for change
this is the same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
this is an emotional debate whatever
side you're on and it cuts to the heart
of what it means to be american
values freedom and constitutional rights
to share their stories with this
committee and the public as witnesses of
these latest horrors in buffalo new york
and uvalde texas gathered to discuss
their experiences is there a sense that
perhaps now things are shifting once the
blood is rinsed away from the bodies of
our loved ones we return again to
nostalgia
to the rose into the view of our second
amendment as a perfect instrument of
american life
no matter how many lives are lost
at the heart of the debate is how to
balance the nation's second amendment
right to bear arms with the need to
control how easy it is for people to get
hold of them part of the issue is that
the laws around gun control are so
complicated and they vary state to state
they are not all decided here in
washington dc
2021 they made it so that you don't have
to have a background check a mental
health evaluation or a license or
training in order to carry a weapon in
the state of texas crucial to this
debate too is the significant mistrust
of law enforcement rather than relying
on the police to defend them many
believe self-defense with their own
weapons is essential
listen to this mother giving testimony
on capitol hill her son was shot in the
head but does she want more gun laws how
about letting me defend myself from evil
i
you don't think that i'm capable
and trustworthy
to handle a firearm
the eighteen-year-old responsible for
the uvalde shooting bought two
semi-automatic assault rifles and
hundreds of rounds of ammunition legally
just days before the attack
an 18 year old with two ar-15 assault
rifles military-grade guns president
biden and many others have called for a
complete ban on the sale of these
weapons
it happened before in 1994 the assault
weapons ban was a bill biden helped to
bring into law
but then the political pendulum swung
the democrats were decimated in the 94
midterm elections gun control was a key
factor crimes involving semi-automatic
weapons did fall but the use of guns not
covered by the ban increased in some
areas and of course manufacturers found
loopholes
[Music]
perhaps more palatable for lawmakers a
so-called red flag laws which involve
allowing authorities to take guns away
from those at high risk of harming
themselves or others
one key proposal if assault weapons are
not banned outright is to raise the age
they can be bought again gun control
laws vary state to state but in general
you only have to be 18 to buy a shotgun
or a rifle a so-called long gun and yet
you need to be 21 to buy a handgun but
in order for any of these potential laws
to pass republicans need to back them
and the democrats hold just a slim
majority in that place and so every vote
for them counts and here we come to the
crux of the problem many senators rely
on the support of those most opposed to
reform
culturally where republicans are right
now
they they look at the second amendment
uh as a litmus test to see if you are
conservative enough if you're republican
enough
the majority opinion that
does want tougher background checks
but but
always runs into the log jam of the
political system and the way in which
the nra and the gun industry
fund candidates who are implacably
opposed to moving forwards on on any
kind of gun reform the national rifle
association the nra is among the most
powerful special interest lobby groups
in the country and it has a huge budget
to influence members of congress on gun
policy
seventy percent of americans now want
gun control laws to take precedence over
protecting the right to own a gun but
the gun lobby's level of influence over
there on capitol hill has prevented
change before and many fear it's simply
too powerful for significant change to
come now
[Music]
god